admettons une idée simple jeu la formule
manière très simple la fin d'un monde
n'est pas la fin du monde et qu'un effet
on voit s'achever une échelle de valeur
qui a marqué la modernité et en même
temps voir renaître quelque chose
d'autre c'est elle c'est le processus
j'ai employé ce mot deux ou trois fois
je vais donner ma référence d'un
sociologue américain qui n'est pas
traduit en france où wim marginalement
qui s'appelle sorokine qui dans les
années 20 des 30 était un grand
spécialiste de la sociologie de la
culture et il a proposé le mot de
saturation la saturation c'est la chose
suivante en chimie les diverses
molécules qui composent un coordonnées
ne peuvent plus rester ensemble fatigue
l'usure et c'est la destruction mais
dans le même temps ces mêmes molécules
rentrer dans une autre composition pour
donner à notre corps voilà les
mécanismes de saturation eh bien voyez
vous si on l'appliquait à ce que l'on
dont on vient de parler depuis tout à
l'heure et pour moi c'est cela le
passage de la modernité à la
postmodernité moi je suis pas anti
moderne
jeudi il ya quelque chose d'autre qui
est en train de naître après la
modernité prenons un exemple
ce n'est plus l'individualisme c'est le
personnalisme ce n'est plus la valeur
travail
céline et de création ce n'est plus la
flèche du temps mais la spirale
voilà en quelque sorte pour ma part ce
qui est en jeu dans le mécanisme de
saturation alors que les connards seul
homme les sinistres host et autres
catastrophiste bien considère qu'il n'ya
plus rien que tout est foutu
toutes les voitures tout fout le camp
c'est or quand on regarde ces jeunes ces
jeunes générations on se rend compte
qu'il ya le sens du qualitatif le sens
du corps l'importance on l'a dit du
spirituel
l'important de valeur que le rouleau
compresseur du matérialisme de
l'économicisme avait laissé de côté et
qui retrouve une force et vigueur
indéniable voilà en quel sens vont se
dit la philosophie progressive peut nous
éviter de tomber dans le catastrophisme
ou dans la chronologie
[Musique]